king of oakland um
i you know you you you procraim yourself
as the king of oakland
um a lot of people think
a lot of people who aren't from or who
aren't in tune rather
they kind of just group the bay together
right it's like
everyone thinks e4 is from oakland no
he's from
he's from vallejo i'm saying a lot of
people think that i'm saying people who
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
like i told you when people think of
cali they think of l.a exactly the bay
even more so because it's even more of a
niche
but like um you have like independently
for oakland done so much
who's like the the og oakland's probably
too short right
so when you say you're the king of
oakland do
do you get any any sort of blowback from
making that statement
um keep it real like
that song i just said that i don't
i was just rapping like it's not even a
hook on the song i just said it and it
became like it
it ruffled a lot of feathers from
different artists but
bav gate years ago was saying he was the
king of oakland
i heard that name in a minute yeah a lot
of people's i'm sure yuctan said it
you know what i'm saying but at the end
of the day the line came out
and i i just named the song that and
and guess what you should feel that way
but short but short didn't say nothing
and big dogs ain't saying nothing and
t.i used to i mean called himself the
king of the south yeah
but he you know he went through with who
he went through with flipping ever but
like nobody from what i've heard
up there that's able to even say
anything that that's able to dispute
that has said anything you saying and
say nothing
you know i got a lot of love for short i
got a lot of love for all the og's from
oakland that didn't
did what they did i look up to them you
get them saying because they did it
before me how can i not you know what
i'm saying especially because they're
from east oakland also
yeah these are the guys that was coming
through my neighborhood these are the
guys i'm seeing when i'm selling dope on
the corner like
looking up to like who i want to be like
come in and hang with my ogs for my hood
so it's no shade to none of them by me
saying that but as in
musically wise and popping i mean who
who doing what they doing consistently
hundred albums
not even just a hundred albums you're
saying that's crazy but even though
that's consistently a hundred i'm saying
like for the past year since i've been
i've been out just in 2010
yeah i'm saying so that's ten years
yeah and a lot of the oakland rappers
that
you know been doing anything it ain't
been consistently it's been hearing
their song here
video there feature here whatever but it
just you know you might not be as hot as
you was this year
but you stand warm because you're still
working and you might pop off again
but as long as you stay consistent
you're gonna still keep yourself in the
groove